- Well, you got married
since the last time.
- I got married, yes.
- I know, congratulations.
- Thank you.
I was actually on your show,
like right before we got
married and I was like,
Kelly, I'm getting married
in a couple of weeks.
- [Kelly] I love the color of your suit.
- Look at that.
Yeah, we did a last minute
wedding where we weren't really,
we didn't think we were
gonna be able to get married
this past year, with the pandemic
'cause we were gonna
have, like, a real thing.
And then in, like, September, October,
we were just like, let's just get married.
Like, why are we waiting?
- Yeah, save your money
and buy something cool,
like a house.
- Heck, yeah.
No, for real.
- Rather than a wedding.
- Yeah, so we planned it
in, like, three weeks.
We had five friends get tested
and we kind of did an outdoor thing,
as you see, on the beach
and we ended up zooming our families.
But I didn't think about that in advance
because you just don't
think about, you know,
zooms and weddings.
And it's like 10 minutes
before the ceremony,
I'm like, oh, we should
probably zoom our families
and so, I'm like frantically
trying to get a zoom link going
and the internet was down.
- I don't know how to do that.
- And so, you know we're
like sending it out,
we're like, we hope we remembered
to send it to everybody,
we forgot a few people.
- I think that, you
know, it's a good pass,
the whole global pandemic thing.
- Yeah.
- It's a good,
it's a good like, hey, we tried.
- We tried.
- There was effort.
- Yeah, and I for sure
saved a lot of money
'cause my family we're
southern, we like to eat.
That would have bankrupted me,
just the food.
- Just the food and drinks.
If you're southern it's
the food and drinks.
- Yeah, my mom doesn't
like any of the fancy food.
She'd be like, you got any sliders?
- [Kelly] Sliders, fried chicken?
- I don't want any of this ahi tuna.
(both laughing)